[Music]
hello and welcome to this video and this
is the first video here for keep it
simple 1d form the first chapter which
deals with d4 d5 side lines so we're
going to look at D 45 a 90 of 3
according to our repertoire approach and
now we look at side lines or some odd
move orders that need to be checked now
um the main subjects of this chapter um
first of all knight c6 this is some
signaling black's idea to play into a
[ __ ] in defense after c4 we would
have a [ __ ] in we will still play g3
which is a good line and according to
our concept of course quite fitting um
and we will look at mostly the tirage
defense to the Queen's Gambit after c5
we will have to play AC form I would
explain to you later wine and then after
6 you would get the tirage depends to
the Queen's Gambit now these two are the
main parts of this this video of this
chapter but there are some oddities that
need to be analyzed as well they are not
very time-consuming to look at but let's
do it
so 9 f3 and what can black do that is
not covered in other chapters um
there is an odd-looking move here that
is to move a 6 this is not really
popular that would be a little bit too
much the same but it has been played
quite a bit by some good players mostly
as a surprise weapon for us it's not
really a big issue the idea that black
is some
I'm having with this is that after c4 he
wants to either take and then try to
keep the pawn or wants to play something
something like e six which leads to some
interesting not very well explored lines
well as it's not a big deal at all
because we're just going to play g3 and
ask like okay what about a6 is that
really a useful move and it turns out
that not so much I mean black can
definitely play this but a6 is something
that doesn't help him all that much
there for example like Knight f6 Bishop
g2 and now e 6 c6 in any case it's not
quite clear what a6 has accomplished so
basically a six young tempts white into
doing something that we want to do
anyway yeah g3 Nazi form so this is not
a big deal us at all um black of course
can play Knight f6 and then we go g3 and
now there are many possible
transpositions out of this chapter moves
like b5 or b6 I've covered in the
Queen's Indian or in the b5 chapter or
black can go c5 or the reverse Greenfeld
g6 would be what we have here in the
chapter on the green felt like plays g6
and e5 there are lots of possible ways
to get into various chapters of our
repertoire now let's have a look at the
first big one of this chapter that is to
move knight c6 ya 96 ya anticipates the
move c4 after which black will probably
play Bishop g4 and it will be a Chico in
defense to the Queen scam but usually
reached by a d4 d5 c-4 knight c6 um I
checked this a little bit and while
white certainly has chances to play for
an advantage that's no doubt about that
I think it makes a lot of sense to just
play g3 here according to our repertoire
concept thing is that this some move
order here for white delaying C form is
actually quite clever in particular
against
96 the main thing here that you need to
be aware of in this line is that black
can play Bishop g4 that is the main move
probably and go for queenside castling
this will turn out to be extremely sharp
and interesting and I think quite good
for white but it is a bit unusual for
our repertoire because mostly we play
systems that are not as sharp but this
is the case where I'm yeah they simply
um yeah throw the kitchen sink and we
have to throw back and if we have to
really fight fire with fire in many
lines now before we get to Bishop to g4
which is again mostly played we need to
check some other lines um black
sometimes plays Knight f6 but this
doesn't really have any independent
value we play Bishop g2 of course and
now black needs to yeah make up his mind
what to do with the bishop yeah Bishop
f5 or Bishop g4 is possible that we will
look at the via the move order
amber black plays the bishop on move
three which makes more sense because
oftentimes the knight is not even that
well placed on f6 let can also play him
the movie 6 that is something that we
check in the Catalan chapter where like
starts with E six and only later base 96
this is also very good for white so we
have to look at the Bishop Museum and as
mentioned Bishop g4 is the sharpest one
and leads to really am grateful
they sometimes play Bishop f5 this is a
more conservative approach and in fact
not that bad but I think White has a
quite comfortable advantage in all
variation so we're playing Bishop to b2
and here black mostly plays the move
Knight to before it looks a little bit
odd yeah or a little bit I don't know a
little bit beginner rush maybe play
Knight b6 threaten here but um black is
forcing our Knight to the No
really optimal a three squared so it has
a point before we look at this however
you can also check other continuations
that are in fact easily dealt with um
there is Knight f6 and I already told
you that this combination of playing the
knight c6 the bishop or Knight f6 is
usually not great the problem with this
kind of approach and the same applies
with the combination of Bishop g4 Knight
f6 is always late and 95 that cannot
easily be taken because after 95 Knight
takes pawn takes the knight on f6 is
attacked we'll see we'll see some line
there to illustrate so we cancel let go
c6 and of course we place before that
it's the way our repertoire works we
delay this move until we have completed
King side counseling and here um black
is not in good shape really because the
knight on c6 is just misplaced piece um
we can look at two lines here to
illustrate black might take but after
Knight bTW 2 we will get the pawn back
in a very convenient way like simply has
no way now to cover this pawn yeah I can
also take before but that is not
playable as well so let's start with
Knight XD for Miriam we will take him it
could be seven and this Bishop this
opponent b7 is just not protected
anymore
after p8 Bishop c6 likes position is
absolutely terrible and what is this
move now maybe I'm very likely winning a
miniature here because Black has to go
into a stealth pin or move the King
which is even worse so after Knight bTW
- he cannot take d4 but the problem is
that if you just allow us to take you
know I'm just not take c4 next we will
have a central advantage and just a very
comfortable position later trying to
play foi and just be better in the
center after b5 we play a4 and now black
is in a huge huge huge trouble if he
goes a 6 and that's the only consistent
move we play 9h form and now we'll see
that we are taking the
can obviously not really move and well
we are threatening um this night and how
do you protect it Queen d7 we have 8x b5
and black and just resigned the game so
this simply doesn't work he come out to
take on C form in this kind of scenario
and be okay so Bishop e7 maybe that
looks a little bit more sensible you
play Knight c3 castles and 95 it is the
idea that I mentioned this is always
going to be a bit of a problem for black
because we cannot easily take this as D
takes e5 it takes the night and then d5
is falling and black has no good
solution to that our idea is also not
just take on c6 which wouldn't be
terrible of course just give him the
double pawn but we can also improve here
with Bishop f4 Roxy won this kind of
play will put more pressure on black so
this whole combination of Bishop f5
Knight f6 like this doesn't really scare
us at all rather the opposite so the
other option is a six yeah black can
play this move first and after castling
play Knight to before this is some
obviously quite similar to the line that
before immediately um
therefore I just recommend 93 and then
we get the same position white can try
to exploit this move water with some
sharp options but I don't think it
really helps all that much just play 93
and allow this
[Music]